oh it's gonna be a drunk night you guys
[Applause]
ah wakanda forever wakanda forever
that's how long it's been
it's been Watchmen so black it's been
watching so black long guys in case you
haven't seen the last time Malcolm was
on the show with me it was literally
Watchman was out and we were discussing
amongst ourselves as we want to do
just how black is this Watchmen show
very black it's so black it's gone now
[Laughter]
bam
think black early and often
so have you been man I've been pretty
good there was a pandemic yeah you made
it though I made it through uh it was
very nice thank you someone's wearing a
Rufus shirt oh
that's how long the pandemic has been
last time I was here the show was on
foreign
ask my girlfriend yeah
um sorry she's here that was weird
whoops that was weird that ought to be
fun
um no last time I was here I don't know
what I do I started trying to do new
stuff because everyone was uh everyone
was worried that their jobs would be
gone some jobs were gone I thought mine
would be gone so I tried every single
thing in the world I was I was
podcasting yeah a half a minute from my
house every Tuesday uh that was really
drunk uh was that uh live with Malcolm
with Malcolm it was going live with
Malcolm with Malcolm because the idea
was that just in case I got fired from
the show it was still you still call it
my show so like when it was my it was
going live with Malcolm with me and in
that way if if I got fired my name was
still on the show I don't know who would
take over Reginald Vel Johnson
going live with Malcolm with Reginald
Johnson I wanted you know what I had an
idea to do to do going live with Malcolm
with Malcolm with Malcolm Jamal Warner
oh
having him take over for me like I would
sit out and like just have them just go
on that way that way we could always
keep the name do you know what I mean
absolutely you got a [ __ ] trademark
copyright yeah did I do a show with
Malcolm McDowell after that you know
what I mean nice just be a series of
that how many malcolms can we get I
don't know
I think I think we'd stopped it too it's
just those
what was his name Malcolm Goodwin
Malcolm Goodwin see I once lost a role
to Malcolm Goodwin uh I really hated it
I called up it was a this is this how
your show goes yeah pretty much okay
so so there's this rule this is real
this is this is a movie being produced
by 50 Cent and written by my boy Cassius
and my boy Cassius wrote this movie and
he's like man I need and this is years
ago maybe eight years ago nine who knows
I don't really have a concept of time I
smoke a lot of weed so so familiar with
it you guys you know what it is I know
how this goes the guy over here this guy
smokes a lot of weed Kevin guy right and
I don't oh okay so that's this night oh
well I've I'll replace Kevin Smith for
you by smoking enough Chin Chin to Kevin
it up Nashville coming out there you
coming out as Kevin Smith I'm sucking
dick out of solidarity
yeah so when we get to q a just line up
over here
and well we're gonna suck dicks from
left to right
and then we'll loop back around and
fondle some balls just to make sure that
everybody's happy I'm dyslexic though so
I have to do the balls first
[Applause]
from the jump so uh there's this movie
uh and my boy catches he's like I gotta
attach it to the movie and I was like
don't attach me it's it's a weird you
know you want to attach people because
you think it'll get the movie done but
to be honest a bunch of [ __ ] happens
down the line who knows things change
he's like no man I want to attach you
I'm like ah don't sweat it and I don't
think he fully attaches me but he's like
you know theoretically you're attached
so later on it comes down the line the
movies being auditioned I'm going in for
another Edition I go I go Cassius man
hey I'm going in for your movie today I
don't know if I'll see you he's like
there's auditions today I'm like oh this
isn't going well
um
so I go in I audition I kill it
um and then he's and then I go home and
it's like days later and I check to see
if I got it and they're like they go
like did you get it who Malcolm yes
Malcolm got it I was like yeah they were
like wait Malcolm what's your last name
it was like Barrett it was like oh no
Goodwin got it yeah
that's the last time you ever heard and
that's the last time any of us ever
heard from Malcolm Goodwin
I'm joking he's a nice guy when the
podcast comes out hey don't worry about
it it's all fine he's this cool guy yeah
Reacher season two watch it he's good in
it he's very good he's good Reacher is a
good show I like it I know I mean he's
doing the job that he's supposed to be
doing what are you doing
okay that's okay because that's better
thanks thank you uh so yeah reach is
good Reacher's a solid Show Malcolm
Goodwin's on there it's starring uh the
tall white guy whose name I don't know
but he didn't have a good time doing uh
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Alan
Richardson yes not to be confused with
Alan Rickman who did not do no did not
played too soon for Alan Rickman
for Alan Rickman
rest in peace George Burns
what are we doing what are we doing yes
that would be too soon that would be too
soon that's too soon who wrote that
oh
I mean sorry welcome back to the show I
didn't kill Angela
yet oh what I know it's such a weird
joke I know it disappeared Midway
through like I had it and then I lost I
just heard her singing um a recording
from Beauty and the Beast and she's
she's absolutely excellent in it um
she's Brit do you guys know Angela
Lansbury is British
that's uh that's all I got for Angela
Lansbury facts that's it she wrote
murders she wrote murders can I tell you
this will not be relevant but to three
people from Brooklyn I would but I was
you probably don't realize this but I
was a nerd growing up and that guy
[ __ ] skinny Santa Claus has [ __ ]
jokes about me
susceptible we're all broken inside
um I was younger and I was at a party
and I was never [ __ ] cooling I'm at
this party I grew up in Brooklyn so it
was you know basement parties black
parties hip-hop reggae's playing all
sorts of [ __ ] and
someone goes now you're seven right
when you're younger I think I'm 12 or 13
right that's when kids dance to music
yeah uh so there's this song If you guys
don't know called Murder She Wrote and
it's a it's a reggae song and goes
Murder She Wrote na na na
um I I didn't realize that and then so
somebody goes oh I missed Murder She
Wrote and I go hey who wants to see a
show about an old [ __ ] solving crimes
anyway
and
everybody laughed because they thought
that I knew that there was a song called
Murder She Wrote but I was not cool or
making a cool joke you were just being
factual another uncool Story of My Life
One time I was playing Urkel in a school
play
what a [ __ ] curriculum is that we're
doing the classics here we all we only
do the class
I'm Professor navel Johnson
we're going to do
you know Vel Johnson Knight every night
tonight you just gotta want it bad
enough
CS please tell us about your time on the
boards at Circle
so it's this made-up play and I'm
playing Urkel because I did an Urkel
impression every plays a made-up play
nice damn it
[ __ ] that's correct
sorry [ __ ] okay so it's this made-up
play that didn't exist previous to us
making it up but still is every play
um and it's rehearsal and I'm playing
Urkel and I get there and they're like
hey did you dress up in character
and I hadn't
and I was so uncool that I didn't even
lie about it they're like did you dress
up a character and I went no
and then I sat there
I Could Have Lied that's how [ __ ]
uncool I was I was like nope this is it
and then two brothers in tracksuits
away looking cool
because they liked to party because they
likes to party they don't cause trouble
they don't bother nobody all right
they're just two minutes on the mic
right
excellent Gene was there when that song
was written
Gene's old it's a joke about my friend
my friend Eugene being gold you guys
wouldn't get it yeah I mean
two mile
Eugene bird everybody
of eight miles
that's became he came to get roasted I
know hey Eugene sorry about that
I'm gonna joke about my girl and what we
do so I mean you're you we're par for
the course at this point how are you
doing Cynthia Cynthia is a
tell me about because because I'm not
going to interview you because that
would be weird because his friends for
too long but yes I don't know oh okay
you're a nerd origin story oh like how
did it manifest for you I know how it
manifests it's a coming out day so let's
let's talk about it sure sure
it is National Coming Out day yeah so
when did you first come out as a nerd
um well really it's people that decide
for you
I thought this was fine no no you know
what's funny
um
one of the earliest there's two early
stories I have one I used to uh make up
comic book stories with my friend tauren
Clark who some folks might know because
he now actually draws for Marvel in DC
and a whole bunch of stuff which we
found out like just on Instagram and
things like that
um I tell this story now because I do
stand up now because I was uh
I had enough of an already career I was
like what let's do a new thing let's do
a new thing let's fail at something else
and so uh I tell a joke about how when I
was younger I used to be into
ventriloquism and uh I had a yeah and
I'm not going to tell a joke for him
when I tell it in real life for him
um wait what
[Music]
they don't let black people be into
ventriloquism
they just don't
well I quit early
if it helps this is the most amazing so
I lived in the Bronx and I was passing
by Bodega and I go inside and they have
a Laurel and Hardy ventriloquist dummies
um yeah yeah real current reference and
and I saw it and I was like huge fan of
Laurel and Hardy
black kid from the Bronx
[ __ ] eat that [ __ ] up I'm gonna stick
my hand in this little white man's ass
what another fine mess you've got me
into
officer I swear
at the house this way and I BR and I
bring these little things home and I
quit early because uh ventriloquist was
hard like
I assumed I'd know how to throw my voice
just because I saw it on TV or something
and so I literally I'm just like this is
[ __ ]
I mean it's hard but it'll get you laid
I mean Willie was deep in [ __ ] well
that's nothing nothing gets you booty
like a little fake wood
talking with jokes and the moral of that
story is the ventriloquist dummy is
still in that Bodega
bread
is a cat yeah
just a haunted Cat Just A Haunted cat
haunted Bodega cat write it
I already did
there's an issue of a comic book that I
do called census that's out today from
comixology issue number two do you like
uh comic books I do love me some comic
books well the second issue drops today
and it's about a bodega it's like my
love letter to bodegas and there is a
bodega cat of questionable
um Origins
oh it's spoiling anymore than that I'll
just say
appears to be appears to be is he
possibly like one of those cats from the
Marvel movies that are like some weird
alien I don't know what they're called
no
flirtkins no not a flurkin okay he's not
about to go
I'm gonna kick his ass later
but you're having a toilet bowl loser
what do you read books stupid
um so yeah that oh to bodegas you never
really answered my question because
ventriloquist dummy is nobody's way into
being a nerd you want to know how is it
yeah I was a math kid I was on the mat I
was on the math team
thank you thank you you're a mathlete I
was I was not a mathlete I was on a math
team and I was one of the top players uh
up until
later
yeah baby
I was acting like there was no tomorrow
uh I think it's crazy mathematitional
gangster they call that playing dice
like I'm really good with these numbers
bams kilo seven no I was I was a math
kid so and I went to a math and science
high school and I was in uh he's one of
them smart kids I was one of those smart
kids that was me they'd be so proud of
you now they all who yeah and now I just
I play some more people now because uh
actually learning things is hard
so so
I play it on TV yes and I memorize
things that smart people say all right
so mathlete sorry math team
I went to Stuyvesant High School which
was the number one Math and Science High
School in the country which is well my
girlfriend is over multiple times from
me and my mom
it was like there's a Fame High School
LaGuardia there was LaGuardia and then
it was Moscow and you'll hear because my
mommy like I don't know if you know this
but Malcolm Malcolm went to uh
Stuyvesant High School it was the number
one Math and Science
um
School in the country at the time I'm
42. so
none of this means anything it does to
me it doesn't do anything so then what
was the okay we I see how you're
predisposed
to nerd [ __ ] yes but what what opened
the door what was the thing what was
they like oh I gotta have me some of
that I'm gonna get all up in this
space [ __ ]
um like if there was a media or a TV
show or something like that star man
tell me this story about this young Jeff
Bridges
it was like naked and hairless the whole
time like I was really into Mac and Me
or something like that or like I mean
Zoobilee Zoo I would be 100 does anyone
here old enough to know Zoobilee Zoo
thank you Santa Claus
thank you
thank you kilcullen
I don't have a I don't have a nerd
origin like a thing what were you into
as a kid what was your jam like moms I
got to be home in order to watch [ __ ]
Six Million Dollar Man or an Incredible
like Six Million Dollar Man I watched
The Incredible Hulk uh with Bruce Banner
or was he David Banner on the show he
was David on the band because they were
afraid of alliteration
they're afraid of lawsuits
that's what I'm afraid of
um I watch The Smurfs
I read Maybe
just booked
I was actually I used to that was the
other thing I used to write myself I
used to when I was in first grade I used
to write books I'd read to the
kindergarteners so I started writing
stories and then that's how I started
getting into doing plays and how I
became an actor it's funny they always
ask like what inspired you and it's like
I didn't see a whole lot of black actors
that I wanted to be growing up or it was
few and far between like I don't know
who I wanted to be like I want to be
like John Amos you didn't want to be I
didn't want to be balding and hoping for
good times
laughs
and yet here we are here we are hey
we're lucky we got him
but I mean like ironically I loved
Greatest American Hero
I love I love Greatest American Hero and
notorious for representation
he's got curly hair
so maybe I was like that [ __ ] he
might have a Jew fro I don't know that's
something
um it's not racist I'm on both sides
hahaha
remember my secret identity
no what
are you joking no oh my God guys do you
guys know my secret identity [ __ ] yes
you and Steve
[ __ ] my secret identity was Jerry
O'Connell was the first time I was
exposed to Jerry O'Connell and he had
sort of powers which was that he could
levitate but not really so he couldn't
really fly so he would take these
aerosol cans and this before we knew
what they did to the ozone layer so
literally it's just Jerry O'Connell
spraying deodorant and destroying the
ozone layer while trying to fly through
the world I'm not even sure he had
powers
um and then Dr Jeffcoat I think was like
his sort of mentor guy here I got too
nerdy for this crowd for this crowd I'm
telling you
that sorry thank you great
he had powers right he had like one or
two Powers Jerry O'Connell he could like
make a left on red like was that his
power
he would like kind of fly almost and I
don't know I just remember Dr Jeffcoat
My Secret ad you'll never guess my
secret identity
I'm sorry
the words I know that's it those are it
uh okay I I was hoping for more but and
then I used to write poetry and I used
to rap and do battles
and uh I didn't ask for your black
origin story I wanted your nerd origin
story
but all right
um I really like Doctor Who
but that was later in life that was like
30. okay
listen this is going nowhere man nowhere
fast
um all right I want to talk about
we're gonna get into the show proper
usually we don't announce that but uh I
did a podcast yesterday with Kevin we
did a fat man beyond and I purposely did
not talk about this program because I
wanted to talk about it with you
Interview with a Vampire
ah
have you guys seen have you guys seen an
interview with a vampire body yes yes
have you guys seen him for the interview
with a vampire yeah alternate Blues
Bruce Willis have you seen
come on Bruno
okay all right
uh I love this show I watched it
no one asked you I watched it I really
like this guy I watched it in
anticipation
of tonight's show yes so I sit there I
don't know I I barely remember anything
about the original uh Interview with a
Vampire I knew there was uh Johnny Depp
was in it okay okay Bradley Cooper
yes Alan Rickman and Alan Rickman
and a young Angela Lansbury
[Laughter]
and Suki
I'll do this show for me I don't care
um
they serve beer and hell
um I I I loved it I I was watching I
couldn't remember anything except for
Brad Pitt and Tom Cruise and I didn't
remember if there was actual
homoeroticism in the in the original
movie or if I just thought everyone was
like no then I was there it was clear
great great issue settled so
I'm watching Interview with a Vampire
and
um you know it opens up with oh here's
how they get you here's how they get you
Eric but here's how to get you
how does the show usually go Eric
bogozian do you guys know that actor
yeah that's how they get you
get me bogosian we need a [ __ ]
close-up
okay
what are the kids talking about Eric
bogozian they love that talk radio [ __ ]
come on monologue me [ __ ]
who's on the show Megan a stallion Eric
bogosian
s first go figure
so so they introduced this [ __ ]
journalist this [ __ ] asshole-esque
journalist and it's it's nothing like
with Tom Cruise the original was he the
journalist Christian Slater Christian
Slater cuffs
yes I loved cuffs you remember cops yeah
um he was a cop
um
so Christian Slater Eric bagosian I
don't know if you guys know nothing
alike no right so they've done this
whole new take
um by making him this sort of curmudgeon
right but then they've also made who was
the guy Brad Pitt before yes as Louis
yeah now he's still pretty but he's
black right like he's a black guy from
he's gray worm from [ __ ] uh the gamer
swords yes yes
[Laughter]
and it's and
you're waiting for like oh [ __ ] the
black's gonna kick into the story when
they [ __ ] they start [ __ ]
African-American ended up how they gonna
ruin my childhood by blackening this
story
it ruined my vampire Story by putting
blacks in it
how are they gonna do it we ruin
everything yeah we do
uh first month first they came for our
mermaids
and I said okay then
now they come to my vampires that I said
no
no draw the line here not this far no
further I want my Undead weight or
Nothing at All
I imagine that's how the letters went
pretty much uh when the pilot aired but
the interesting thing about it is that
you're waiting when they do that story
you're kind of waiting to go like how
will they change this or or what you
know will they will his experience
um be told within the story and so very
early on there's a guy he grabs he's
literally a pimp and he grabs this white
guy and he he calls him the n-word and
and he says and he says in the most
eloquent way he says something to the
effect of like
uh suck my dick I don't know but
the most eloquent way of saying most
eloquent way but he does it so well and
it's very interesting because you sit
there and you go oh this is like crazy
and interesting thing and it's
interesting because as a black person
you sit there and there's a part of you
that is waiting for the authentic
experience of having that person live
that life right and really because
you've sat and watched whitewashed
things for so long that you've become
accustomed to that that when something
actually speaks to your experience and
uses it in a way that is authentic and
natural you go there's something that
hits you in here you're just like oh
[ __ ] like yeah no that is something
that's that's interesting and
overwhelming and I made about the joke
about The Little Mermaid but that's
that's how used we are to see anything
that was like wait this made up creature
is black yeah yeah yeah because it's
made up
um and so that was really interesting to
see is how it played because it was very
authentic and how it played into it and
the story and the Poetry of the words
I've never seen or I haven't heard such
beautiful
um poetry in terms of dialogue on
television in terms of just and it's
fairly modern text it's it's it's not
that elevated a text
um but there were usage and their word
choice is so beautiful and so eloquent
and so surprising at every turn and so
we're resting With Every Beat and with
every interaction and so it's one of
those shows that very immediately draws
you in simply with language with story
and with conflict and that was just
amazing to see even with the music and
the score and the way they undercut how
things would go the expectations you
would have
um were really beautiful and in the name
of coming out day super cool gay sex in
there really cool gay sex yeah I mean I
remember the homo homoeroticism of the
book but I don't ever remember it being
explicit I remember that's what I said
that's what I was thinking it was very
much like oh no it's all kind of subtext
and it's all unspoken and we're cutting
away from these scenes before people are
going to [ __ ] get naked
um but to make it explicit and to make
it part of Louie's Journey as a black
man as a gay man as a gay black man when
you couldn't be either and succeed in
any real way and then to have Lestat
run into that story as a rich white dude
from the continent
who has a surface level understanding of
race in America especially race in
America in New Orleans where he can say
things like oh they shouldn't treat you
that way Louis it's it's awful that they
do that I would never treat you like
some kind of exotic animals okay but you
also just did you know like Lestat
doesn't know what he doesn't know and so
we'll say the things that are still kind
of [ __ ] up and reek of the privilege
the character is supposed to have and
it's it's fascinating how they've
deepened what I mean I haven't read the
book since high school I remember loving
it that and vampireless thought
um were the two like Anne Rice's that I
dug into I didn't go much deeper because
then I got weird and Chicago and racy
um but those two were the kind of the
the The Duality of those two stories
about there's one vampire and the other
vampire it was very it was very kind of
modern in The Meta textuality of it
but to see it enriched enriched and
enliven with a sense of place a sense of
race a sense of Class A sense of
privilege a sense of of longing a sense
of pain and then the Contemporary story
which doesn't wipe away the the
Christian Slater version of it it just
incorporates it like I was a younger man
says Eric bogozi and the last time we
sat down and I wasn't ready to have this
conversation but now I am so suddenly
all that other [ __ ] was text and all of
it is Canon but now it's a different
conversation and I just love how it's
incorporating all of it and updating all
of it and infusing it with what feels
like a modern story even though it is
now 40 years old if not older and it's
amazing because it's also one of the few
stories I've seen about black people
during Jim Crow that isn't strictly
about subservience
um which is something that's not
explored like that's one of the things
that I get annoyed about slave movies is
just like other [ __ ] happened there's
more there's more story than he'd be
beat me and I ran away and so like this
was really interesting because it was
like yeah we smiled before
1933.
we had some good days it was one it was
a good day it was one of two good days
before and after the Civil War uh and so
like well that's always what's
frustrating is I think people forget
that stories are about conflict and I
think people are afraid to put in
conflicts that they don't know and
because of that you wind up writing a
story that isn't true and isn't
authentic and when you could add those
elements in a way that's true and
authentic and interesting it's fun and
that's also what you want at the end of
the day you want a really interesting
fun story and that was what was amazing
is that the second half of that show
surprised me every five minutes it
surprised me with the story development
with the relationships with
the the life and death with the gore the
violence
um with the music uh with the ending all
of it I was just surprised at every turn
and
it's what you want that's what you want
out of horror that's what you want out
of any story is just to be surprised
enthralled and interested did you see
the second episode I didn't and it's
because I I was getting high
I mean priorities are what they must be
I get it I mean but it's it's similarly
really good because it does follow all
those threads but there's a great moment
and I'm not going to spoil too much
except Eric bogosian the great Eric
that's how you get the kids that's how
you win like just breadcrumbing your way
and whatever Kodak Black and Eric
bagosian
one time only until listen we could have
gotten Selena Gomez with like 400
million uh [ __ ] Instagram followers
but no we got the OG bagozian bring me
to BOGO
buy one get one but gozi vergosian
um but he asked the question and I won't
clarify the question but he just asked
it more than once in the most deadpan
way I've ever heard so did you eat the
baby
um
so did you eat the baby
best question I've ever heard in the
show that's a great question did you eat
that baby did you eat the baby I wrote
down some notes
about the show really yeah yeah you did
homework yeah yeah uh here's another
you're not supposed to do homework I do
the homework right watch I wrote down
two things all right uh oh there's three
things this is the last one's a bit
I like to let tell us where we're gonna
go yeah I don't want you to be surprised
by the journey
everyone hates surprises the GPS yeah
yeah if I was your GPS I'd be like ah
you're almost there
time I think this is it close
um my favorite lines from the show are
Eric bagozzi is trying to interrupt him
and tell him what's happening and he
goes let the Tails seduce you say oh
[ __ ] I took off my home
took off all my [ __ ] I wasn't even
wearing nothing until I took it off
uh my other one is um
I'll tell you [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up hold
on let the tail seduce you
uh the second one was uh you played
docent to the gentleman vampire
wow you played doubtion to the gentleman
vampire what
that's right
and in the third one
this isn't a writing thing this is a
this is an observation okay
um my favorite part is
um all right spoiler alert two
three
four there's a threesome
okay how you doing your eyes perked up a
little bit how you doing man I like I
[ __ ] with your whole spirit
right a threesome
it's only Tuesday
but okay she's like she was like they're
a little late
um it's my Friday usual so don't play
docent
um
is that a camera yeah
um
see there that's the internet [ __ ] out
of here yeah man
hello Internet
it's already on the internet that's
crazy man technology so let me get one
of these what kind of feathers is that
y'all still doing that
well you had a drink
that was beer I want a wakanda forever
what it is can I get one of those I
could yell at you because it's wakanda
and I'm black
[Laughter]
I have given everything I have to give
if I'm not done enough
for one more wakanda
my son
would like another drink
so my last my last favorite part is that
you're slow so making a drink
he's muddling [ __ ] videos he's doing
a lot I know I'm being an [ __ ] I
apologize there's a mortar and a pestle
I'm gonna yell as soon as I get it
though I'm gonna turn around uh my other
favorite thing is they're having a
threesome and let's start this is is uh
the brother Lestat and the sister in the
middle
um and and he goes sleep well
and does like this and puts her in an
orgasm and she's like oh and she does
one of those those one things where
they've they've forgotten to be sexy
anymore where they just
[Laughter]
it's just against the pillow you know
what I mean
because she's just breathing out or
whatever just not touching the pillow or
just
the two people not laughing you you know
why
change your game up
thank you coloniza
[Laughter]
oh never mind never mind yeah yeah wait
what kind Mexican or Spanish what do we
got
because one of those history yeah yeah I
think I wouldn't know
yes [ __ ] Latino past me
no thank you for the drink though
earnestly
that's what I'm saying
listen man I don't know
somehow you uh you derailed me but I
wasn't even on any rails yeah yeah
the sex scenes are lovely
[Music]
this brother why are you looking at me
so serious you're looking at me like you
produced for Conway the machine like you
do
that's for the two people in here that
love hardcore rap
I hope you're happy I am I'm okay I
don't need to please everybody
all right we're gonna talk about some
news now
great this is the part of the show
where huge news fans huge news fans
where according to Kevin I go on the
internet and I copy and paste news from
people who've reported it I've heard
this yes that is my role in this podcast
is I spend 45 minutes copying pasting
[ __ ] genius hell yeah it's a way to make
a dollar my friend I like it you're rich
uh-huh uh so we have talked long and
hard on this podcast and in the world
how excited we were for mahershala Ali
to be playing the day to Green Book yes
yes
black book
greener
Yellow Pages
I just gotta know where to get a plumber
foreign
[Laughter]
you guys know what the green book is
all right good you didn't need a movie
wait do you think it's the movie or the
book
all right thank you sir you've never
stop surprising me
I love that about you I love that about
you
you're cool
what if I was earnestly afraid
um yeah [ __ ] rehearsal Ali you guys
know this movie Blade
you guys you guys you guys hear about
this movie Blade
not not Zorro the Gay Blade no not Zoro
the Gay Blade which is the best kind
which
bro was my favorite movie was it when I
was like 12 years old I only
put them into cinematographer
my name is Alonzo Hamilton George
Hamilton's younger brother and I shot
Zorro the Gay Blade
also George Hamilton references I mean
who's this podcast for
me
and Kevin Jesus Christ and like-minded
individuals
basically you need to be like 48 or
older yeah
um no zero the Gay Blade was my [ __ ]
Jam when I was a kid because a Zoro Zora
is always cool zoro's always cool it's
always cool and more than jazuro there
was his cousin bunny Wigglesworth who
dressed in all kinds of [ __ ] colors
when he had to take over for Zorro who
sprained his ankle that's the plot of
zeldick did you not know what happened
to saw the gameplay let me tell you
something I did not know oh let me tell
you the plot of zero the Gay Blade in in
in in celebration of national coming out
day I will tell you what happens in Zoro
the Gay Blade tell me everything so
George Hamilton is playing Zorro right
if you guys don't know George Hamilton
actor from the 80s 90s always Tam super
tan but so he's playing
um Diego De la Vega right and he's
[ __ ] Zorro yes swashbuckle black
satin the whole Jam all that good sword
fighting rides a horse named tornado
does all kinds of cool [ __ ] helps the
people of out the California and get rid
of their [ __ ] Spanish colonizers
um and then he busts his ankle right
doing some Daring Do [ __ ] but the people
need a Zorro they got to have this they
got to have a zero and so in comes his
cousin
notoriously gay
which is not to be confused with
Notorious B.I.G no who also happens to
be like his identical twin cousin which
happens apparently named Bunny
Wigglesworth who is like can you take
over to be Zorro while I'm healing up
and he's like of course I can would love
to except I gotta do Zorro my way right
got to got to so he opens up the [ __ ]
chemise right and here it is just
[ __ ] wall-to-wall pimp clothes it's
just like purple and pink and yellow and
orange and Periwinkle and just all of it
it can match the Hat had little [ __ ]
tassels on it and [ __ ]
but Periwinkle is a very gay color if
it's not a gay color it's at least the
gayest word like that that word came out
today
Periwinkle was like it's my time
this is it it was always though it was
always very little time
um and so but he's also like a legit
[ __ ] badass swordsman but he adds
wait for it a whip okay that's his thing
he's got the [ __ ] sword but bunny
cracks out a [ __ ] whip on
[ __ ]
and and fights crime in Alta California
yeah no that's amusing yes 100 amusing
but here's the [ __ ] it's also a really
good Zoro movie also hella gayzoro movie
except there's no sucking of [ __ ] or
nothing because it's 1981. I like that
the movie's not fully gay it does at
least two three [ __ ] are sucked
how's Brokeback Mountain it's all right
it's pretty straight
didn't see any dicks getting sucked
yeah
you you see milk it was okay
was it gay no no dicks got sucked
it's very interesting
so this movie is completely not
problematic
no not at all
um I would recommend it for families
because that's how I watched it really
yeah because it's also a really [ __ ]
wholesome Zoro movie oh that's cool
that's cool
okay I'll watch it great uh I don't know
why blade zero the Gay Blade Blade how
did we get
[Applause]
Boom Blade we're just doing word
association tonight right these are
particular who's got an occupation
uh so yes this is give me a situation
in this movie was supposed to be coming
out uh next November we're supposed to
be supposed to begin production in a
couple of months
um but in the wake of parting ways with
the director Basim Tariq and what seemed
to be problems with the script marvelous
person pause on the Vampire movie
uh the the movie's dead it's it's gone
what I suggest
is just watch the original blade it's
really good it's a solid movie
did you see it
[Applause]
no man tell me what happens in Blade
okay it's about
it's about this vampire right what is
your family like a day Walker though
okay you see New Jack City yeah it's
that dude that dude that dude's a
vampire Nino yes Nino Brown's a vampire
Nino Bettencourt is a vampire at some
point he goes always but on black and
then kills uh everybody so wait what
happened to passenger 56 then I think he
died before passing in 57.
thank you
he died right before wow it's crazy 56
know that if he was one seat over he'd
have become an immortal day Walker
nothing like in other vampires some
[ __ ] always want to skate
uphill
on Ice if preferable
oh man this was almost a podcast once
I'm not here to help at all
I'm here for chaos
chaos
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's over nine billion [ __ ]
there's only 20 000 police
can you dig it
can you dig it
[Applause]
that was uh the Warriors yes
foreign
how are you doing man
so blade blade
uh yeah I was I'm you know it's these
things are weird it's weird when a movie
gets stalled because you automatically
go oh I bet the movie's gonna [ __ ]
suck they took nine more weeks or four
more months for this thing that didn't
exist before anyway and who gives a [ __ ]
but like now now we feel away like oh it
took a couple more months and I don't
know I don't know what it's gonna mean
Marvel hasn't completely [ __ ] the bet on
anything there's things I've liked much
less than other things but I don't know
I don't know what this means what do you
think this means
um I think it's actually a good thing
because I think it means that they don't
want to give us a shitty version of
Blade and so they're going to take the
time to find the people that can make
them the best version of Blade and so
rather than race to meet a release date
I'm like you know what [ __ ] it let's
hold back let's let's take our time in
as much as we can take time because at
some point Marshall may or may not ever
look a day older than he does
I don't even know how old he is he could
already be 72 years old I have no idea
he got them good black jeans man
super black jeans super black so black
how black on my Ursula Ali's jeans but
her Charlize jeans are so black
[ __ ]
went up to the edge all right up to the
end I don't know rehearsal all these
jeans are so black they started dating
white women when they moved to Hollywood
[Laughter]
it's the first thing that came to mind
there's nothing I could do you just
gotta write it out you gotta ride it out
rehearsal Lively jeans is so black I'm
pretty sure he has sickle cell
I do
I'm waiting for that call uh rehearsal
at least Jesus is so black anyway let's
move on
I don't know I think you got one more
um they they just got fired by zazzilov
wow
[Laughter]
bam they won't let it in the water
Brothers
[ __ ] yeah
[Laughter]
is that dream killer who is this oh yeah
you look familiar
who are you what did you do where you
come from are you dream killer are you
my personality
Ursula Ali's jeans
are so black
I'm not doing it
it's so black Herschel Walker won't
claim them as his kid
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Herschel Walker
laughs
[Laughter]
what's up Lamont
political humor
dearly beloved
uh all right so yeah blade is probably
going to come out but later and I don't
know when
so that's what we gained from this
conversation that's all we got that's
that's what we call tying a bow [ __ ]
excellent suturing that up was that the
news that was just blade oh okay that's
blade news y'all blade news did you guys
watch my Hershel Ali on
What's that show called Luke Cage
all right that's all that's all it was
good he was good in it
he wasn't even the blackest person on
Luke Cage he wasn't Alfred wooder might
have been Alfred wooder should play
blade
yo
does she age she's the same age you've
ever seen her in
you actually look like Alfred Woody's
husband I've met I've worked with Alfred
Woods Bernie he looked like a jazz
musician
he wears like little hats and he's like
like scoliosis
like like I'm married now free with it
we don't age and I got these rickets
he's a cool guy he's a cool guy uh oh
you hang out with a lot of famous people
uh are you are you caught up on Hot D
House of dragons yeah got it I also the
dragon are you are you watching the Hot
D can I tell you this no no not at all
but
so I don't watch House of dragons
because it's uh I got nothing against
white people
laughs
but it's just it's just I hate the
conversations around it I hate
everything that's happening I hear I
hear the shows is it different even I
hated the whole wiser black guy in a
blonde wig thing or a white wig and I
was like what like they don't naturally
have white here I'm like white people
don't naturally have white hair at Birth
I don't know a white haired girl
you know blonde people that's not white
that's the end of my rant I haven't
watched the show so it's not informed
it's not knowledgeable or informed it's
just 30 seconds of me thinking
outstanding uh well George R.R Martin
thank you oh you read a thing
look I copy pasted more news
things that hot D needs Four Seasons to
tell its story according to him I have
quotes yeah Four Seasons 40 episodes we
got out of this
um
I have House of the dragon have 13
episodes per season maybe we could have
shown all the things we had to time jump
over though that would have risked
having some viewers complain that the
show was too slow then nothing happened
as it is I'm thrilled that we have 10
hours every season to tell our tale
um rings of power has this blah blah
it's going to take four full seasons of
10 episodes each to do justice to the
dance of the dragons from start to
finish
you know what I'd love to do tell me I'd
love to when I pitch a show I just feel
like look it's not going to get good for
another six seven years
first six years just chill out just ease
up into it
slow it down I had to do how I did it
because that's how we got to do it
now the 14th year
that's when the show kicks in the gear
that's when we tell the story
that's a wild [ __ ] to say
yeah I I suppose you can say that [ __ ]
when you're sitting on a mountain of
gold you can I don't have that mountain
so I'm like hey man when's something
gonna happen or when's a thing going to
happen to a person that I care about or
when am I going to care about somebody
like that's that's my problems with
house with hot D is that the Game of
Thrones is happening and shit's going on
but I don't know who the players of this
game are anymore so sometimes it's
episodes but why is that blonde child in
the dark whose name I don't know riding
a dragon whose name I don't know and why
is that a thing I'm supposed to care
about
and I never get answers to that and then
it's like oh yeah now it's six years
later and that child who's blind is now
grown up and blonde and they turn the
lights on in the scene so I can see
what's happening and then it's oh now
he's a grown person who's having [ __ ]
static with his cousins uncles Brothers
I don't know everybody's [ __ ]
ancestrous so I don't know who's related
to who anymore but now why why is why is
any of this happening
I I will so we're in a chat together and
I will in one of the sections is about
the show and it just sounds like a drunk
person who just woke up from a dream
discussing what's going on they're like
look I was wearing and then he's gone
now and then look seven years later I
don't know I'm the king
sounds like it's very it's very Wicky
entry
yeah it was just like oh this happened
to him the name aegon IV and then aegon
the fifth showed up who did this and
there were dragons 12 of them they all
have names syntax guy gagax pie facts
Gen X Phil uh lintax like just the
[ __ ] list of dragon names and I'm
supposed to give them all straight
because
do the dragons have names on the show oh
yeah really
yeah you know what you answered it the
first time I just wanted to like up the
Kool-Aid man just a little bit like oh
yeah I get that yeah I get that is what
is a big Mortimer or they name stuff
like that cool stuff like that well like
it's funny because like the kid like
every fourth name on the show like it's
oh it's visiris and rhaenira and aegon
and Damon and Jason like
Jason
which what you couldn't there wasn't
another [ __ ] up name what's your name
Allison how wait huh I wish it would be
like thorax Durex Shaheen
Levin yeah Centaur
renisha yeah
JJ
TT thermos
like that that's how old is he keeps a
hot side hot and the cold side cold you
know what I'm saying yeah
I'm saying you get it I get it so yeah
we got four more seasons of this coming
um
because people are watching it and I
don't blame them isn't it one of the top
rated shows it is because it gives you
that hit
of Jones yeah and like they play the
song and here we are with all these
blonde people like oh it's a Game of
Thrones which I loved until I didn't but
sure give me more
and it's got the dude from morbius
it's morbin time every episode
you guys see morbius
it's not a good movie
it's not a good movie I just want that
on the record good the internet
remembers not one thing you don't have
to remember I don't like that movie I
don't like Mobius and green book those
are my two least favorite
recent movies you know what hell is for
me me watching Mobius in green book
on two separate TVs at once yeah
just you can't even close your eyes I
don't want it next to Liam Neeson
I don't want it you don't want it uh
what Kanye West giving me commentary
[Laughter]
I got no time for Kanye
I do have time for grand opening
Quantum Leap gets more episodes
so here's my one thing about Quantum
Leap tell me
I don't like the writing I think they
let
I mean like it's serviceable for Network
I think they let too many people be
writers
um
anyway my boy Derek Hughes writer of
Quantum Leap is here today
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but yes Quantum Leap from Derek Hughes
in the corner uh the first season has
now been up to 18 episodes so uh a plus
for Derek who gets to keep working
and for people who get to keep watching
if you're digging on the Quantum Leap
people kept telling me I don't know if
you guys know this but I used to be on a
time travel TV show
and uh I so the show is called Timeless
and uh and there were people who hit me
up they'd be like this is the weirdest
part because people people get angry
before they see things I don't know if
we live in a society
where
come on we're people with people Snyder
cut uh where people get angry beforehand
so they're all like they're all like man
[ __ ] Quantum Leap man you should be in
Quantum Leap man only there's only one
time travel show man [ __ ] that [ __ ] and
I'll be like hey man my buddy writes on
the show be nice just be nice people you
know it's okay you know and there's an
Asian guy in the lead like
shout outs to Asian people
Give It Up
it's like I'm always going to be
deferential first to minorities I like
colored people
I know if I'm drunk enough talk about
just like colored people that's what I
thought mark
I'm gonna go back to Calabasas where I
feel safe
uh anyway so uh Grand closing
the man oh oh oh I get it I get it it's
a two-part thing so grand opening guys
is about how it is more of Quantum Leap
yes grand opening we're starting Grant
closing you're about to announce
something that got canceled yes calm
down negro's in the corner
so loud
are they this loud on MSNBC oh my God is
that where they hire you I know they
hire you to talk on the show but now you
could just chill
my buddy Jason guys
[Applause]
yes Dr Jason Johnson he gets paid to
talk and he thought he was getting paid
tonight I guess
we about to cut off
Jason Johnson ladies and gentlemen
um he showed up early
texted us and went hey I showed up too
early I got the time wrong I'm gonna get
some food then showed up late
[Applause]
what an interesting combination what a
way to no he's just what an angle he's
zeroing in he's eventually going to get
it he's triangulating yeah he's
triangulating towards the time that's
cool I like your shorts
confident choice
but in the night time well yeah
it's formal in Bermuda he is he is this
is true very much so uh Grand closing
the man who fell to Earth
or irf if you're Will Smith yes
um canceled after one season looks like
his ratings fell to Earth
I don't know if they ever got escape
velocity oh I don't think it ever left
her what this was what you're for sure
yeah the homie Chewie I just like how
you just went fast through it I'll go
quick
anybody if I made a name I don't know I
just quick through it they're like hey
my name is whatever I go Summit here we
go
I love you good to meet you I'm not
gonna hit any speed bumps we're just
gonna power right through this video
move on did you watch that show I
watched the pilot of that show
Okay so
uh it was it was well done just not my
jam and I I'm a big fan of Sherwood
legend for sure
Cheryl
I'm not gonna disrespect this brother on
black man Beyond at the wrong time call
him Cheryl
with them
you know I feel like his career will be
okay either way he's gonna do fine I
think he's gonna be all right he's he's
gonna he's gonna hang in there
so uh so we'll learn a letter for each
year he's famous
there's a w in there
what are you friends with him
you Buddies
I would like to be
Jesus
it's got really huge fans of 10 Years a
Slave
we left off the last two for savings
[ __ ] I've never saw the movie
I won't see it
sorry
still love him he's great I just I'm not
gonna see it that's fine
we're out of news
and scene
all right so so now is the part of the
show where we uh we turn to you the
audience to help generate content
because we got lazy and one of us got
drunk
laughs
and uh and the way it works here at scum
and villainy uh for black man at fat man
beyond it's your book it's my book we
got giveaways for questions if you ask a
question you get a present
um one of those presents is a copy of my
comic book a door and the distance
which is currently sold out of its print
run so you cannot even buy it in a store
but I have three copies here today
ask a good question
walk walk yard
it's not eight miles from you to hear to
ask a question come on get him Gene get
them
get them Gene
in addition to the book we got we got
two tickets to a 40x location of your
choice
um 40x if you've never seen a 40x movie
it will it will avoid you of any kidney
stones you might have
no it will realign your spine in ways
that you might not ask for but it will
be an immersive cinematic experience I
like this uh photo because it looks like
this couple thought they were going to
have a normal date and a love seat on a
highway and it just got weird
we're moving why I thought it was just
us uh I think Halloween kills is about
to be in 40x and sorry Halloween ends
Black Adam is about to be in 40x I want
to see Black Adam and uh and black
panther will come to Forever what kind
of forever it's gonna be forever forever
this accent we're doing is not good I
mean it's just good it's most of that
movie sex at work was
first off those were authentic wakandan
accents
on point and if you say difference
you're wrong
there's no way for them to be incorrect
no it was perfect
those are real accents Game of Thrones
happened in a real period of time these
are all real things they are mermaids
every play is made up
uh so JC Batman himself
all right
um before before we jump in I've got
some wait do you not Banff into black
man beyond I I don't think I Banff into
Cantina shows unless I get like smoke
capsules or something
all right fine if you just wanna
you just know I mean I could fake it bam
there it is
[Applause]
it it's just what it could be right
unless we had I I have a a couple fun
comments from the chat first uh video
void TV says I love this replacement
host he's great really funny
yes Kevin got inclusioned out of a job
laughs
uh Leah demy says the wakanda forever is
working it's magic
Mike also the movie
oh
uh yeah you're right
[Music]
Mike Lynch says I want this every week
please
David Moore says oh my God this is the
best thing ever every week we demand it
and then Leah Demi followed up with not
enough wakanda forever for Mark to talk
about Kanye
[ __ ] Kanye West
okay now we can do q a who's who's got q
a questions
guys ask otherwise it's weird you know
yeah that's like real quiet hey man hi
what's your name my name is James James
welcome aboard so we talked a lot about
blade yeah
I love blade when I think of Blade I I
hearken back to the days of Ron O'Neill
Youngblood priest Superfly
and Curtis Mayfield if you could pick
any artist or band or group from back in
the day till now to write the blade
mahershala Ali blade theme song and
soundtrack
who would that be and how to go
all right uh do you have a feeling about
this I do what's your feeling I'm going
to say these three names are going to be
out their mind
T-Bone
Pharrell
and uh
what's the name Tony Tony tone
Rafael Sadiq it's like Tony
he said it three times like how you keep
losing his name
[Laughter]
Raphael Saadiq Pharrell and T-Bone
together together
yeah I want that you want that and uh
throw you off hmm the dude from Nine
Inch Nails that be doing music Trent
resident yeah
that
would be amazing I want that I want that
I want that
I put them all up I get in the money
all right
I mean I kind of if it's got to be
contemporary
excuse me I keep on having to pull these
little Blackberry seeds out of my drink
I get that
um I think silk Sonic would be cool
I think Anderson pack and Bruno Mars and
that would be [ __ ] tight
um
Kendrick would be cool but I kind of
really want like Bootsy Collins
yeah I want like Bootsy Collins I want
George Clinton I want that Parliament
Funkadelic Vibe I want
I want panties to fall down you think
that's
this guy who really loves blades
foreign
you think that would be dynamic enough
for the action and the violence and the
gore that happens at blade
I'd like to see him try interesting yeah
interesting I think it'd be interesting
I think it would be interesting okay
because I think silk Sonic could get you
there six iron will get you there but I
mean so I can make my funk to P-Funk
because I want I was like if my if
Boosie made a modern sort of song I
don't know his most modern [ __ ] but if
he made something that went to the score
of a [ __ ] blade thing I think I could
[ __ ] with that
I'll [ __ ] with that you guys [ __ ] with
Bootsy Collins
yeah I know Steve do
Steve's my homie yeah
we did a movie that uh the budget was
eight dollars together
the Forgotten
oh hey that's what I [ __ ] with this guy
yeah oh James you forgot your present
I walked away thank you James
James all right who's up next hey guys
oh come over there I gotta come under
the light all right
um
so you guys were talking about Black
Adam real quick yes there's been serious
romance about Henry Cavill finally
coming back into the fold right and so
I'm curious how would y'all utilize him
in Black Adam and then DCU going forward
and what do y'all think that means for
Michael B Jordan's Superman movie that
was in development
well I'll speak first because I know
less
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh I don't know anything I'll go
um honestly I I would be excited to see
a Superman that was a little more jovial
I think Henry Cavill was actually uh an
amazing Superman and I think just the
story honestly I'm one of those people I
actually really liked Man of Steel I
just thought it should have been
brighter like like I really don't have
like that many bad things about it the
the rest of the stuff but uh I'm excited
to see Black Adam I don't know that
it'll affect Michael B Jordan's
character that much or how it would only
because they are two different
characters but it's really just about I
guess whatever imagination you can use
to cultivate what those stories would
look like like I still don't know what
what what they're going to do for that
origin story initially so that that
would be interesting I don't know for me
there's just too many things up in the
air to like have any idea and I'm one of
those really simple people that are like
if it's a good story it's good like I
think you can make whatever as long as
you're good and creative and like do the
things where you make a good story but
that's just me
um I think
I'm I I liked Henry Cavill as Superman I
just don't think those are particularly
good Superman movies
um there's parts of Man of Steel that I
do respond to quite a bit although I I
have gone on record saying it I I like
Zack Snyder as a person I moderated a
panel that he was on he was a very nice
guy we got along famously
um but I don't think those movies quite
understand who Superman is
um because
I agree
and so the thing that I like about Henry
Cavill being in Black Adam is that it
does
I think it gets to close a door in a
chapter you know and I think it does get
you like all right here's the thing you
wanted we don't have currently a
Superman or Superman movie and and even
development really let alone production
we don't know who that's going to be but
there should be a Superman in it because
that's the fight you want in the Kingdom
Come comics it's Shazam but that tone
doesn't work because Black Adam it would
be like punching a child a lot and like
nobody really wants to like oh don't hit
that but Zach Levi like what did he do
he just learned to fly
um so you need somebody like Titanic for
him to go against and it makes some
sense in that way but I wish that they
could have used it to launch what was
going to be the DC movie Universe going
forward but they're not there yet they
don't have the Manpower they don't have
the development folks they don't have
the plan
so it feels very much like their
spot welding it's a bit like oh well
yeah the chips and we are holding the
ship and atmospheres leaking out what
are we going to do well we should buy a
new ship but that's going to take time
to just weld that [ __ ] shut so we can
make it to the end of this movie Warner
Brothers is like the rich kid who has a
lot of toys and a lot of expensive
clothes but they don't know how to put
them together or what they should look
like or any style or what to do with
them or and they don't like the black
kid that lives in a neighborhood
my earlier analogy was Marvel was the
nerd who got his first girlfriend but it
spent his entire adolescence reading and
learning and watching until he gets his
girlfriend knows exactly what to do how
to please her how to treat her right DC
had the big ass dick but had no idea
what to do with it just waving it around
just [ __ ] ran it out knocking it up
against walls and [ __ ] like we got
Superman and Batman a Wonder Woman and
look at all this and Marvel's over here
like but we got this Captain America guy
he [ __ ] I swear he [ __ ] just you wait
so he got Iron Man he's never heard of
before and we don't even have Spider-Man
we don't have the X-Men we got these
four Schmucks but we figured it out
though we went to work we went to the
books we trained we did all the tongue
gymnastics and now we get in that [ __ ]
we do the work
DC was like I'll make Joker a musical
just look at my dick
[Music]
so I feel like
yeah so DC is still in that period where
they kind of need to figure their [ __ ]
out DC is America
let me explain
[Applause]
please continue explain okay okay here's
why okay like [ __ ] other countries
they look at us and they're like you
guys have so much [ __ ] potential man
you guys are like [ __ ] cool man I
like it you guys what are you doing
Independence that's cool I get that
right and then we're like yeah and we
got guns too we're like okay yeah no we
yeah we have guns too I guess if we want
but like let's just like chill and
figure [ __ ] out and DC's like no we get
it we've done this look at her [ __ ]
thing America boom
foreign
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you for your question
it's a good follow-up good question
there you go man
[Applause]
all right we got one last question one
last question one last question
bring it home
all right here we go Malcolm yeah this
question is for you it's more personal
um I saw your character on a couple of
films and I wanted to know what your aha
moment was after NYU
your success moment was after school
after you left when you thought you'd
like done the thing oh my first TV show
uh uh Louis with Louis with Luis Guzman
so here's what's funny about that he
looked at that corner like uh his wife
because I've I've talked about the show
because I did it I came here and so it
got me here 2003. but I always go Louis
with Luis Guzman because there's a
subsequent Louis that has different
connotations so I I'm always very
specific about it but that that's when I
knew that's when I felt like I made like
I had I'd been doing whatever but I'd
come I'd been in LA and it was like I am
on a TV show there's my name is on doors
I've got a parking spot no car but a
parking spot
let's go lay down in it I just got like
oh this is nice and I don't [ __ ] Park
here it's mine
um and honestly one of the that's one of
the first times where I felt like I made
it but one of the first times I knew I
had taken a step in Hollywood and I
think I've told this story is you know
you go to the studios and the studios a
lot of them will have remnants of the
movies you've seen and you don't even
realize it right so
I go to one Studio I can't remember what
it is maybe it's Universal maybe it's
not
um and there's the giant wall that looks
like a sky or a river and it's from The
Truman Show right Jim Carrey and it's
it's the moment at the end of uh Truman
Show hate to ruin this 20 year old movie
um spoil spoilers for this [ __ ] thing
you should have seen already
um but at the end of it to walk into
like he goes to an ocean it's a horizon
but it's not real right visually it's it
just looks like it and he goes there and
he opens the door and he says goodbye to
his life as the guy who's inside this
show within a show and he walks through
to the real world to realize whatever
that reality will be for me I go into
the studio and I see that wall I see
that wall which was fantasy I see that
wall that's reality I see that wall that
is the bridge to the next step when I
walked into the studio and every time I
walk into a studio I see that wall I see
the bridge between fantasy and reality
and I realize I've crossed to a world
that I had no idea what it would be or
what would happen and I took that step
to that door and every time I go to a
studio and I audition and I see new
people and I go for a project I step
through that door not knowing what'll be
on the other side of it so that was my
moment
[Applause]
it's funny the the Paramount lot also
has the big like [ __ ] the weird
skywall but it was the the tank that
they shot the end of Star Trek 4 in yeah
so it's like the whale tank and so they
they put they have to Klingon ship and
there's Kirk and thuggins bogging Bones
and [ __ ] also got a clamoring on it and
so when you're a guest at the Paramount
lot they Park you in the tank so like
you drive on and suddenly the ground is
blue is you're like oh I guess I'm
parking in the shitty tank that nobody
else was the parking because it's not
close to anything and it you couldn't
shoot there today because it's been
janky for a while but it's always like
oh
there were whales here
I almost feel like that Paramount tank
might be The Truman Show wall and I just
don't know the difference it could be
and that's the magic of Hollywood the
magic of Hollywood
uh well you forgot your gift and your
your your [ __ ] even though only one of
us could answer that question that's
fine thank you
thank you
um
I think that's a show is it
I think it is
[Music]
how long was that I uh
well you know we did we did a 90-minute
show ah how much do I get paid how much
you get paid you got paid in a drink and
a half [ __ ] Hollywood
[Applause]
uh have you had a good time tonight
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
everybody in the house
um if you have had a good time tonight
it is entirely thanks to a JC who lets
us into his bar he's coming villainy
here on Hollywood California Hollywood
Boulevard and the great and wonderful
and amazing Malcolm Jamal Warner
everybody
[Applause]
Cosby's innocent
I love that those are your last words
Cosby's innocent good night
one over the crowd uh
[Laughter]
I'm not sure he's guilty as Sin yeah
yeah I'm not sure when we'll be back but
it'll be soon enough but until that time
uh I have been Mark Bernardin
[Applause]
I've been Malcolm Barrett
and bigger applied bigger Applause
and this has been black man beyond uh
[Applause]
thank you for spending a Tuesday night
with us we'll be back same black Time
same black Channel smodcast.com or
youtube.com Kevin Smith
peace love and soul
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]